hey youtubers is Charlie so big news the
flash movie just lost this director just
like what happened with Deadpool two
very similar situation someone explained
what's going on he does make it sound
like a disaster but it's not that bad
the headline you may have seen makes it
sound way worse than it actually is when
you read that like the real reason for
him moving on for him leaving the
project it makes a lot of sense it does
sound exactly like what happened with
the Deadpool 2 movie you know director
has an idea for a vision of the film it
isn't necessarily in line with like the
universe that the studio is trying to
create so if you remember all the
craziness earlier this year with the
transition to the Jeff Jones era of DC
films I think this director Ric family
what was brought on before that
transition had been made in before they
had reevaluated what they wanted their
film universe to look like so like a lot
of that transition happened while they
were making the Justice League movie so
no surprise that when they changed their
focus in Hollywood it takes a long time
for that to actually bear fruit
so whereas they kind of started making
these films in a really dark gritty
universe and that was kind of like their
go-to thing like okay we're going to
differentiate these from other Studios
comic book films by making them super
dark super serious and visually stunning
audiences are extremely divided on that
take so in comes Jeff Jones in this sort
of like recenter a lot of their
character work on sort of the true
spirit of the comic book characters so
like even if you have characters doing
things that they didn't do in the comics
the goal now is to keep the true spirit
of the characters alive in the movies so
it makes total sense that the director
of the flash movie now had like this
darker grittier version of the flash
universe than they wanted to go with so
they decided to part ways like what
they're doing is trying to prevent
another Suicide Squad situation where
you have a director you know who has
like a really interesting idea for a
film but halfway through the process
they decide that the audience wants
something different so they try to
change the film after they've already
made a whole bunch of it so they're
basically trying to prevent a complete
nightmare down the road so it's probably
going to happen now is they'll find
another director it'll totally be fine
but it will
cause the release date of the movie to
get pushed originally it was supposed to
come out March 16 2018 meaning that
depending on how long it takes to find
another director it'll just get pushed X
number of months I don't think it would
get pushed any later than spring 2019 I
don't think it'll be that late
they might just choose to release it
later in the year in 2018 but if you
remember James Gunn said this really
interesting thing where he said he felt
like a lot of really good ideas for big
movies not just comic book movies but
big movies in general got ruined because
the studio's announced release dates
before the scripts were finished before
everything was figured out and I would
say that the biggest problem you have
today with movies is that people are
putting films and theaters up they
decide when a movie is going to come out
in a theater and then they start work on
that project well the way it used to be
is people used to write a screenplay
when the screenplay was good enough the
movie would get greenlit and then they
would make that movie so the screenplays
were better today they decide when a
movie is going to come out based on
whatever that IP is that product and
then they have to write to meet that
date and the script isn't good enough in
six months you have to write that
screenplay then they still have to make
the movie no matter what because they've
already committed to a date and I think
it's really destroyed a lot of the
quality of filmmaking and that's why so
many movies are so bad so now it sounds
like both Marvel and DC are just taking
their time a little bit more and getting
these movies done which i think is going
to be much better in the long run as
much of a bummer as it is that we won't
get the flash movie quicker we'll get a
much better movie rather than try to
rush out a half-baked version of a flash
movie you know better to wait a couple
more months and get like a really
awesome movie rather than get a couple
months quicker and get a really terrible
movie so let's talk about tone because
that's actually a really big thing that
was the big point of contention that
caused the director to leave it sounds
like they're trying to go with something
that reads maybe closer to say like
Geoff Johns run in the comics imagine
the tone of those they weren't always
like really light and happy but they
were certainly a lot more hopeful and
sunny than what you've seen in the DC
movie so far so you can understand how
like that vision would clash with doing
something really super dark and
but as far as we know that doesn't
necessarily mean they're going to be
changing a whole bunch of plot or the
big villains supposedly the Rogues were
going to be the villains of the flash
movie so like Captain Cold was going to
be the big bad but they had released
some concept art of the flash movie
version of Captain Cold and he just
looked like a complete nightmare like
the scariest version of Captain Cold
you could possibly imagine so far
different from the TV show I'm totally
cool with the movie looking completely
different from the TV show I think
that's kind of the goal is to just kind
of do their own version while at the
same time being very true to the spirit
of the Barry Allen character but you
could just imagine the hilarity of a
bunch of little kids going to see the
flash movie and just all the nightmare
fuel of what like this dark version of
the flash might have been the good thing
about this though is that by the time we
get to comic-con next year they will
actually have some flash movie stuff to
show us because they'll be getting ready
to roll out Justice League so like
really Justice League will be the big
thing that DC's promoting at comic-con
next year
that's a November movie so you know
comic-con end of July they'll have like
a whole bunch of Justice League stuff
but because it takes about a year in
post-production to get a movie out
they'll probably already have a bunch of
Flash movie stuff shot to put you know
depending on when they find their
director when they get the script and
when they start shooting so just be
prepared for delays to happen and really
I think you know when they talk about
the shifting tone of the DC movies in
the geoff johns
era Wonder Woman is going to be the
earliest example that like Geoff Johns
was heavily involved in the development
in the script for Wonder Woman so just
remember cycling directors out you know
stuff being changed at this point in
time is really just an example of a
transition from like the old DC movies
ethos to the new Jeff Jones era so I'm
also really interested to see how that
affects the Aquaman movie just because
there's so much like undersea horror
going on I think it's going to be a lot
of fun this is the Jason Momoa is going
to be something of a swashbuckler in the
what just sounds like a lot of fun like
you can't go to a Jason Momoa movie
without having fun but in related DC
news I know I just talked about Wonder
Woman there is a new Wonder Woman
trailer like an actual new trailer
dropping with dr. strange this
in the United States so that will
probably post on like Thursday maybe
Wednesday night so whenever that comes
I'll totally do a video for it so be
sure to subscribe to get that and
there's a whole bunch of DC and Marvel
stuff happening this week I'll probably
post a Supergirl Fight Club video
tomorrow morning they're basically doing
like a Fight Club episode on Supergirl
while she just beats the out of a
lot of people Miss Martian is part of
that too so it's going to be a lot of
fun and deccan Lachman is coming on the
show as roulette so that'll probably
post before the flash episode post
tomorrow there's some infamous Iron Man
Doctor Doom stuff that I want to do from
the comics so yeah it's gonna be awesome
don't worry you know flash movie you
know like it sounds like terrible that
the director would leave but it's really
not that bad
Geoff Johns I've come to bargain so what
you guys wait for that next video to
post you can click here for the flash
trailer for tomorrow's episode and you
can click here for my non-spoilery
Doctor Strange review thank you so much
for watching everybody let's high five
I'll see you guys tonight